[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro d' europe hebdo je suis
ravi de vous accueillir ici au parlement
européen à strasbourg
c'est parti pour une demi-heure de
décryptage de l'actualité européenne
dans cette édition nous partirons dans
le nord de la france dans la région de
calais l'un des points névralgiques des
échanges avec le royaume uni tous les
jours plus de cinq mille camions de
marchandises font la traversée sur des
ferrys alors à cinq mois de la sortie
effective du royaume uni de l'union
européenne dwan et entreprises locales
s'inquiète du flou qui entoure les
négociations
notre reporter est parti à leur
rencontre nous débattrons ensuite des
conséquences d'économique de cette
incertitude autour du breakbeat avec nos
trois invités
mais d'abord cap sur l'italie sous les
projecteurs de l'actualité européenne
cette semaine avec cette décision
inédite dans l'histoire de l'union
européenne
le rejet par la commission du projet de
budget italien pour 2019 un budget jugé
hors des clous par bruxelles
écoutez le commissaire européen aux
affaires économiques nous ne sommes pas
face à un cas borderline nous sommes
face à une déviation qui est clair net
assumer et par certains même revendiqué
je vais m'arrêter sur quelques points
qui me semble essentiel premier point
pour dissiper un malentendu la
commission ne remet pas en cause les
priorités du gouvernement
d'abord c'est le gouvernement italien
qui légitime pour diriger ce pays
ensuite ses priorités qu'il s'agisse de
la relance de l'investissement ou la
lutte contre la pauvreté
pour ceux qui connaissent la situation
italienne sont des priorités qui peuvent
faire sens la commission ne va pas
interférer en quoi que ce soit dans ses
choix interne est légitime ce qui nous
préoccupe c'est autre chose c'est
l'impact budgétaire de ces politiques
sur les citoyens sur le peuple et c'est
là-dessus que porte l'opinion que nous
venons d'adopter et pour en discuter
j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir sur ce
plateau mercedes bresso bonjour vous
êtes italienne membre du parti démocrate
en italie et dans ce parlement européen
vous appartenait au groupe des
socialistes et démocrates alors 2 4%
déficit 1 ça reste en dessous de la
barre des 3% qui est le critère de
maastricht
pourquoi finalement et bien le budget
italien été rejetée parce qu'en réalité
le traité de maastricht comprendrait
deux volets un le déficit le déficit
référé aussi à la dette globale
comme vous savez le problème de l'italie
c'est une dette à plus de 130 pour ça
elle était arrivée à 5,23
elle avait commencé légèrement abaissé
et donc l'engagement que le gouvernement
italien a pris tous les gouvernements
italiens qui se sont succédé gauche 3
technique a été de baisser
progressivement le niveau du déficit
jusqu'à arriver près de zéro de façon à
pouvoir commencer à réduire la dette
essentiellement le problème est là l on
prends souvent l'exemple de la france un
qui a un déficit supérieur au déficit
italien pourtant et bien son budget
n'est pas rejetée pourquoi alors dans ce
cas la france a fait un accord de
descente progressive et elle a continué
selon les accords à réduire le déficit
donc elle reste dans les accords et
l'inde est nettement inférieure qui
frise maintenant le 100% donc elle aussi
elle doit à le réduire mais elle a eu
son fondamentalement un peu plus de
temps pour pour le faire parce qu'il
était vraiment un niveau de déficit très
élevés elle pointe de la france était le
déficit
l'italie est là un excédent budgétaire
primaire c'est-à-dire avant le paiement
de la dette
excellent depuis très longtemps le
problème c'est que le poids de la dette
est énorme
65 milliard d'euros seulement pour le
service de la dette ce qui veut dire
quand vous voyez que chaque année on
soustrait 65 milliard à des politiques
de développement de croissance dans la
pauvreté
on ne peut pas continuer à dire aux
italiens que il nous faut de la
flexibilité parce qu'elle flexibilité
signifie plus de dettes et je ne crois
pas que les jeunes italiennes puissent
être complètement détruit dans leur
futur par une dette qui devient
insupportable
alors ce budget italien il doit servir à
financer un certain nombre de mesures
sociales promises par le gouvernement
italien
augmenter la retraite de base pour la
porter à 780 euros
créer un revenu universel pour 5
millions d'italiens faire revenir l'âge
de la retraite à 62 ans et enfin baisser
les impôts pour les petites entreprises
il est présenté par le gouvernement
italien comme le budget du peuple
l'ensemble de ces mesures
représenteraient un coût qui dépasse les
21 milliards d'euros finalement mercedes
bresso est ce que c'est un à la
commission européenne de rejeter le
budget d'un gouvernement qui a été
démocratiquement élu
comment monsieur moscovici il rappelé
c'est pas le budget qui a été rejeté
même si moi en tant qu'italienne je peux
me permettre de critiquer et je
considère que les mesures sont des
mesures de type assistance seulement et
pas de mesures qui puissent relancer
l'économie créer de la croissance et des
vrais emplois
je ne pense pas qu'on puisse offrir aux
jeunes italiennes et aux chômeurs est un
lien seulement de l'assistance or le
revenu de citoyenneté pour les plus
pauvres existe déjà avait émis par notre
gouvernement
mais c'était vraiment une mesure tampon
dans les situations dramatiques ce qu'on
doit faire c'est créer des emplois de la
croissance et s'assure sa malgré les
mots
il y a rien absolument rien alors en
tout cas la commission européenne a
donné trois semaines à l'italie pour
réviser son budget elle si elle ne le
fait pas elle s'expose à des sanctions
financières pouvant aller jusqu'à 0,2
pour cent de son pib
est-ce que mercedes bresso il ya une
chance que l'italie révise son budget
j'écoutais malheureusement je ne crois
pas je crois que les italiens sont ne
sont commencent à ne pas être content
être en plein doute et donc le conflit
avec l'europe vous savez c'est très
souvent comme ça en europe on prend le
confie avec l'europe comme une sorte
d'orgueil national
mais bon là c'est pas question d'avoir
de l'orgueil national moi je pense que
ce gouvernement est en train de détruire
l'italie et donc que la commission a
raison je ne crois pas que pour le
moment ils vont choisir la chose la plus
raisonnable que ce serait de négocier en
europe il faut négocier parce que honey
on doit tenir compte des idées des
autres alors fin septembre le ministre
de l'intérieur italien matteo salvini
déclaré personnes à bruxelles ne peut me
dire que ce n'est pas le moment de le
faire
et si à bruxelles ils disent que je ne
peux pas le faire je m'en fiche je le
fais quand même il a également réagi
mardi en déclarant nous ne retirerons
pas un seul euro de ce projet de budget
un député de la ligue 1 a même piétiner
les notes de pierre moscovici à l'issue
de sa conférence de presse en celui ci a
réagi sur twitter par ces mots ceux qui
écrasent des textes et des décisions à
coups de chaussure ne respecte ni les
règles ni les institutions ni la
démocratie finalement mercedes bresso en
tapant du poing sur la table
est ce que la commission ne risque pas
de raviver le sentiment eurosceptique
on était peut-être que oui mais je crois
aussi qu'il faut rappeler à tous les
européennes que l'europe c'est nous et
donc que les règles que nous avons
choisis sont des règles communes
choisies librement sur lesquelles on est
d'accord le budget qui avait été
concorder entre le gouvernement italien
est la commission a été modifié
radicalement
saini latéralement je crois que ces
attitudes de type fasciste ne paye pas
tous ceux qui tapent et les points hauts
les rôles et soulier sur la table sont
finit très mal et je pense que ce soit
96 finira très mal
merci beaucoup mercedes bresso d'avoir
été notre invité aujourd'hui on prend
maintenant la direction des ports de
calais et de boulogne sur mer dans le
nord de la france où les inquiétudes
grandissent alors que les négociations
sur le brésil font du surplace là bas
les entreprises locales ne savent pas
très bien à quoi s'attendre
après la sortie du royaume uni de
l'union européenne quid des contrôles
douaniers et sanitaires après des
décennies de libre circulation des
marchandises avec le royaume uni
comment cette zone d' échanges
commerciaux intense avec les
britanniques se préparent au breakbeat
c'est un reportage signé samedi à deux
chiffres
[Musique]
on
au large de calais se croisent les
ferries qui relient l'angleterre à la
france en 90 minutes
plus de cinq mille camions font chaque
jour la traversée à leur bord une
mécanique bien huilée que le break site
pourrait enrayer
24 heures sur 24 la brigade des douanes
supervise la ride et des ferries ici on
est quand même en frontière
assez assez levé c'est pas un contrôle
systématique
la plupart des chauffeurs ne sont pas
contrôlés entre le royaume uni et la
france
les marchandises circulent librement
c'est le principe du marché unique
européen mis en place il ya 25 ans seuls
quelques camions sont priés de s'arrêter
les douaniers les choisissent tel
instinct comme vous pouvez entendre
normalement le frigo parce que c'est un
camion rigide frigorifique fonctionne on
l'entend donc potentiellement des
produits frais produits alimentaires à
bord une cargaison de bananes de
république dominicaine une plaque
tournante du trafic de cocaïne en voyant
la marchandise serait taxé sur un
contrôle de stupéfiants potentiel le
chargement est homogène
à aucun moment il n'est question de
déclaration douanière
les contrôles ne concerne aujourd'hui
que la lutte contre la fraude
mais au lendemain du bric site
le royaume uni ne fera plus partie du
marché unique européen
toutes les marchandises devront donc
faire l'objet d'une déclaration
douanière
tout l'enjeu c'est de rétablir les
formalités douanières et pour autant
maintenir la fluidité donc c'est pour ça
que la doit notamment y avoir 700
emplois supplémentaires sur trois ans en
termes de douaniers pour justement
traiter ces déclarations en douane qui
vont être déposées à l'importation ou à
l'exportation
pour autant ce pas dire qu'il y aura
plus de contrôle y aura pas forcément
plus de contrôler si les formalités
douanières sont bien anticipé ces
nouveaux contrôles seront dématérialisés
les camions qui auront correctement
rempli une télé déclaration douanière
avant le voyage n'auront donc pas à
s'arrêter
mais le bric site signifie aussi le
retour d'un autre type de contrôle celui
des normes phytosanitaires un contrôle
physique qui pourrait ralentir fortement
le trafic à 30 kilomètres de calais la
zone logistique de boulogne-sur-mer le
coeur du marché européen de la pêche
une partie des poissons et crustacés qui
transitent par les entrepôts de
l'entreprise delanchy arrive du royaume
uni at war
la rapidité est au coeur du métier des
transporteurs voilà pourquoi philippe le
maire craint le retour des contrôles
sanitaires en cas de brick site sans
accord la france contrôlera la moitié
des lots de crustacés comme l'exigent
les règles européennes
d'autres pays pourraient se montrer
moins scrupuleux il y aura plus de
souplesse sur des pays tiers que sur la
france
encore une fois bruxelles défini et
après chaque état mais en application
dans 100 ans dans son pays
tout le monde ici craint la concurrence
des ports d'anvers et de rotterdam
le gros danger c'est la délocalisation
de la place de boulogne-sur-mer au
profit des pays des pays belges et
néerlandais
si le trafic se détournent vers
l'étranger cinquante emplois pourraient
être menacés dans cette entreprise de
transport et bien plus sur l'ensemble de
la ville à quelques mètres des entrepôts
de lenche y l'entreprise jc david et la
dernière en france à fumer
traditionnellement le hareng
c'est nos ancêtres qui fumait comme ça
aujourd'hui il ya des mi moyens
mécaniques qui sont beaucoup plus
agressifs pour les poissons
là ça nous permet effectivement d'avoir
un poisson qui garde toute la texture et
on mange vraiment du poisson est pas dû
une fois son sexe pour livrer ses
produits une entreprise familiale comme
celle ci dépend des gros transporteurs
son directeur général a peur de les voir
partir
aujourd'hui on produit nos produits en
continu on a pas de stock chez nous et
on répond exactement à la demande les
demandes qui nous arrivent le matin
entre 5 et 7
on l'est on les produit dans la foulée
et on les envoie avant midi un peu
partout en france
demain si on n'a plus à l'eau de la zone
je loge ici que l'on a aujourd'hui ça
risque d'être beaucoup plus compliqué en
termes de gestion de production
personne n'est aujourd'hui en mesure de
dire quelle sera l'ampleur des contrôles
sanitaires impliqué au lendemain du
breakbeat rien ne filtre des
négociations qui s'éternisent entre le
royaume uni et l'union européenne
[Musique]
et pourront discuter j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir sur ce plateau alain cadec
bonjour bonjour vous êtes français
membre des républicains et dans ce
parlement vous appartenait au parti
populaire européen et vous êtes par
ailleurs le président de la commission
pêche de soi face à vous aujourd'hui
marc tarabella bonjour bonjour vous êtes
belge membre du groupe des socialistes
et démocrates
et pour compléter ce plateau j'ai le
plaisir d'accueillir karima delli
bonjour bonjour vous êtes française
membre du groupe des verts et vous êtes
également rapporteur sur le corridor mer
du nord méditerranée et présidente de la
commission transports au cc sera le mans
alors première question pour vous alain
cadec on comprend dans ce reportage les
inquiétudes dans les zones portuaires à
la proche du break site qu'elle va être
avec le retour des douanes l'impact sur
les échanges commerciaux
il va être évidemment important et ce
qui nous inquiète nous français c'est le
fait que la commission européenne est
complètement oublié volontairement sans
doute les ports français dans le cadre
des nouveaux échanges que nous pourrons
avoir notamment avec l'irlande je pense
évidemment à brest à roscoff à cherbourg
wavre puisque la route qui va venir
d'irlande qui est prévu par la
commission européenne
le corridor en quelque sorte irait
d'irlande c'est à dire de cork dublin
irait directement à zeebrugge et anvers
à rotterdam et ça nous paraît d'abord
politiquement inacceptable et
stratégiquement incompréhensible
justement au profit des ports belges et
envoie dans ce reportage dans la crainte
dans la zone portuaire du nord de la
france de la concurrence des ports
belges et néerlandais marc tarabella
permettez-moi d'abord de revenir sur
votre reportage qui est très bien fait
et qui souligne l'importance et l'aspect
positif que revêt le marché intérieur
rappelons que ce cabinet libertés
fondamentales y en a quatre liberté pour
les biens les services capitaux les
citoyens sur tout et on se rend compte
que le bric site décision on va y
revenir mais bon voulue par les
populistes et puis le peuple a suivi on
voit tout l'aspect négatif de
retour en arrière qui consiste en une
sortie d'un pays de l'union européenne
et donc effectivement il ya des impacts
dans les autres pays bas l'homme dans
l'aspect portuaire est évidemment
souligné ici l'aspect concurrence est ce
aussi quelque chose qui m'ennuie un peu
dans l'europe d'aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
ne parle jamais que de concurrence
concurrence loyale non de non faussée et
de fêtes et une compétition et c'est un
peu regrettable parce que je pense que
l'on nous sommes complémentaires et je
pense que le port d'anvers n'a pas
besoin du poisson de la mer du nord pour
être prospère le port d'anvers et de
rotterdam ce sont des porcs sur le monde
la pêche plus spécifiquement c'est vrai
que boulogne sur mer un rôle clé et
j'espère le garderait à l'avenir moi qui
suis belge je le dis sans aucun problème
avec mes collègues français alors vos
karima delli aux est originaire du nord
de la france est ce que vous craignez
les impacts de ce break site sur cette
région en particulier comme on le voit
dans ce reportage
alors il faut bien comprendre deux
choses c'est que pour l'instant moi je
suis partisane de dinde il il faut un
deal si un deal il va falloir qu'on
s'organise c'est-à-dire ce corridor
c'est quoi c'est une nouvelle route du
fret maritime pour justement la fluidité
des activités entre les ports européens
et l'irlande d'accord les premiers est
sur cette frontière
ce sont les ports français parce que
justement c'est la première vitrine
c'est la raison pour laquelle je suis
d'accord avec mon collègue monsieur
alain cadec pour dire c'est pas normal
que le tracé il n'ya pas les ports
français donc notre mission est de
remettre les ports français et ensuite
il va falloir travailler sur le fond
pourquoi parce que si on a un deal ça
veut dire qu'on va pouvoir négocier une
période de transition durant cette
période on va pouvoir équiper notamment
nos ports sur un volet sanitaire ça a
été dit a volé
vétérinaire etc a volé administrative
remettre des contrôles cdh administratif
ça veut dire que nos ports aujourd'hui
ont besoin de trois temps un temps des
espaces parce que par exemple sur le
port de calais que ça a été évoqué là
nous dans notre commission on a fait une
projection puisqu'il ya une grande étude
sur les conséquences du break site à
calais c'est deux minutes par camion
ivanova il va nous falloir 27 km
d'infrastructures pour pouvoir gérer les
contrôles par exemple oui donc la grande
peur c'est y aider la cie de camions
énorme alors que les liora des files de
camions donc il faut des aménagements
des espaces
deuxièmement il nous faut un des
investissements et je le dis sur votre
antenne
il n'est pas normal que des régions qui
ont subi des crises que soit la bretagne
que ce soit la normandie où que ce soit
les hauts de france subissent de plein
fouet les conséquences du break izard
que c'est pas eu c'est pour ça que je
demande un fonds d'indemnisation pour
ces régions qui vont devoir s'adapter
si demain on met tout sur les ports
d'anvers ur de terreau dames ce sont des
ports français qui mettront la clé sous
la porte il est hors de question de
prendre justement cette option là c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous sommes
parlementaires européens la commission a
fait une proposition mais ce n'est pas
elle qui fait du dégustatif c'est nous
et donc nous allons rectifier le tir
donc vous parler de la nécessité un
karima delli de trouver un accord un
mais la plus grande crainte c'est
évidemment celle du no deal la sortie
sans accord la semaine dernière un
sommet européen était consacrée au
breakbeat mais les négociations ont fait
du surplace
on écoute jean claude juncker le
président de la commission européenne
qui s'exprimait à l'issue de ce sommet
je suis convaincu que sous la direction
de donald tout ce que nous parviendrons
à un accord avec le royaume uni
mon hypothèse de travail va dans ce sens
un odile serait dangereux et pour le
royaume uni et pour l'union européenne
alors c'est un jean claude juncker
plutôt optimiste à l'issue du sommet la
semaine dernière
qu'est-ce que ça signifierait exactement
1 odile marc tarabella
quelque chose de terrible parce que ça
veut dire ça voudrait dire que ben on
sait que problème irlandais pourrait
ressurgir
frontières physiques entre la république
d'irlande du nord
exactement et la république d'irlande
qui appartient lui en européenne exact
mais c'est aussi moi je pense davantage
aux citoyens trois millions de citoyens
européens vivent et travaillent au
royaume uni il faudra et font concours à
l'essor de l'économie britannique
que vont-ils devenir écoeurant devenir
le million et demi de citoyens
britanniques qui vise beaucoup en france
en espagne
souvent dans les zones plus ensoleillé
il faut que le droit des gens soient
respectés et c'est la contradiction de
ceux qui ont voulu le break site
ils veulent un vrai que c'est dur mais
le vrai que c'est dur ça ça veut dire
rétrogradation de droit pour les
citoyens
et ça il faut qu'il le dise franchement
ils ne le disent pas mais c'est
clairement ce que ça signifie dans les
faits et malheureusement les citoyens
risquent d'en payer le prix mais aussi
l'économie des travailleurs et ça c'est
problématique
mais ceci dit moi j'ai toute confiance
dans la négocier des négociateurs
européens ont mené par michel barnier
parce que lui c'est ce que c'est le
marché intérieur il a été un excellent
commissaire au marché intérieur est
évidemment il est toujours été un
adversaire de l'europe à la britannique
c'est à dire le che rue picking au monde
et on prend ce qui nous convient ils ont
toujours fait ça pendant 40 ans ils ont
pris ce qui leur convenait c'était
surtout le marché intérieur le marché
attend à cela le reste leur politique
ils n'en n'ont jamais rien eu à faire et
aujourd'hui qu'ils veulent parti il
voudrait le beurre et l'argent du beurre
et c'est surtout ce qu'il ne faut pas
faire ou c'est un break site soft qui
préserve le droit des citoyens
mais les propres excite vont encore se
faire les choux gras de cette situation
ou 7 après que si dur mais alors ils
n'auront plus les mêmes bancs avant il
ya des établissements le droit de douane
et c'est l'économie des citoyens qui
vont en pâtir
mais cette question de la frontière
irlandaise pardonnez moi elle paraît
assez insoluble karima delli
elle paraît insoluble mais en même temps
il ya deux scénarios qui sont sur la
table
premier scénario c'est de dire désolé on
remet une frontière du parce qu'il va
poser des problèmes
aucune des parties ne le souhaitant ni
britanniques et les irlandais n'en
veulent plus et n'en veulent pas du tout
puisque ça a été acté avec ce qu'on
appelle le pis faille des actes on a
unifié justement les deux
les deux irlande donc on peut parvenir
et en même temps la faveur des contrôles
de marchandises pourquoi parce qu'ils
sortent du marché intérieur
donc lorsqu'on dit on va mettre en place
une union douanière on a les
conservateurs britanniques qui disent
hors de question nous ne voulons pas et
c'est ça le point de crispation et
d'impasse sur lequel il va falloir
trouver une
un accord mets à votre question qui est
très intéressante c'est que se
passe-t-il si liliane odile je crois que
marc tarabella l'a dit sur le volet des
citoyens etc
mais c'est une sortie brutale du marché
intérieur
les conséquences sont terribles pour
notre économie pour deux choses la
première chose c'est qu'aujourd'hui en
angleterre il ya beaucoup de parfois de
non respect des normes sociales par
exemple
hélas le dumping social va être quelque
chose qui va s'amplifier c'est la
première chose autre exemple très
concret je le donne à chaque fois pour
qu'on se rendre compte c'est l'aviation
les avions et des compagnies aériennes
britanniques doivent avoir un accord
notamment du ciel unique européen c'est
le marché intérieur
si on sort brutalement du marché qui a
pas d'accord
tous les avions restent au sol donc de
très graves conséquences sur très très
nombreux secteurs alingué voilà il ya un
secteur qui a impacté de manière
dramatique c'est le secteur de la pêche
ont vu que je connais le mieux ce serait
comme je le disais tout de suite au
dramatique parce que rappelons quand
même que 65% consomme au dos des apports
ont crié en france oat france normandie
bretagne viennent des côtes anglaises de
pêche sur les côtes anglaises anodine ça
voudrait dire au départ un non accès des
bateaux des navires européens au à la
zone économique exclusive britannique
donc ça ferait évidemment des
entreprises qui qui ce qui tomberait qui
n'existerait plus est par ailleurs le
britannique ne respecterait plus non
plus les principes de la politique
commune de la pêche ce qui serait
dramatique sur le plan de la ressource
est un élément quand même
marc le directeur avec juste raison ils
veulent souvent le beurre l'argent du
beurre et davantage il a quand même un
élément qui pourrait les motiver c'est
que 70% de leurs importations viennent
sur le marché unique qu'ils en profitent
du marché unique 70% de ce qu'ils
produisent en matière on pêche et
d'aquaculture viennent sur notre marché
donc c'est évidemment un élément de
négociation important mais anodine il
serait encore une fois dramatique
totalement de dramatique pour la pêche
européenne pas seulement la pêche
française la pêche européenne c'est vrai
pour la pêche belge la pêche allemande
la pêche polonaise pour la mer du nord
notamment
mais pour la manche et la mer celtique
ce serait absolument dramatique en tout
cas un vous l'avez dit les 27 se montre
très unie dans ce dossier du breakbeat
et défendent d'une seule voix leur
marché unique face à une theresa may
fragilisé par la fronde des partisans du
breakbeat dans son pays on écoute ses
réactions à la clôture du sommet la
semaine dernière notre volonté je l' ai
déjà dit à plusieurs reprises et dans ce
contexte évidemment de préserver
l'intégrité du marché unique qui fait là
aussi notre force ça alors je prendrai
beaucoup de travail avant et il y aura
encore des moments difficiles
alors que nous entrons dans les
dernières étapes des négociations mais
je suis convaincu que nous parviendrons
à un bon accord ce qui est dans
l'intérêt du royaume uni mais aussi de
l'union européenne dernière phase de
négociation intérêt à mais en parle mais
le temps presse tant le président selon
cinq mois pardonnez moi mais là ce sont
des incantations ce sont des grandes
banques sur le président macron ou
theresa may sondés sont uniquement des
incantations 51 signifie qu'on veut
c'est des actes et je rejoins marque
tout à l'heure quand il disait que
michel barnier est un excellent
négociateur il fait le maximum il se bat
pardonnez moi l'expression comme un
chiffonnier pour obtenir un accord mais
c'est pas mais 90% le chef d'état faire
ses incantations qu'on va qu'on va
avancer
mais un accord a été trouvé sur 90% à
peu près oui mais l'exécution qui reste
c'est sans doute le moins compliquée et
de passer 10 % étaient tout à l'heure si
le problème de l'irlande
c'est un gros tas vont prendre c'est le
noeud du problème une théorie qui met
toute personnelle mais les britanniques
qui sont le généralement les gens
organisés moi je fréquente depuis une
quinzaine d'années sur parlement se sont
déjà organisés qui savent où ils veulent
aller
généralement les y atterrissent ici pas
du tout
deux ont admis que le bric site a été
votée il ya eu des hésitations dans les
négociations l'europe est prête
michel barnier est prêt il ad il a des
plans il sait de quoi il discute mais
parce qu'ils ont peur marque
ils ont peur et justement je me dis
qu'il ya peut-être jamais de break 6
c'est ce que je dis ils ont peur de voir
ses hésitations je me dis si en soi
c'est peut-être une stratégie parce
qu'ils ne peuvent pas faire revoter le
peuple une deuxième fois au royaume uni
c'est pas du tout à la mode
alors justement samedi dernier où il ya
eu à londres une grande manifestation
700 lits pour la chambre votera sûrement
un jour le fait de rester sur l'article
50 on peut plus reculer
on peut plus reculer trouver un job
management jeanjean clôture guerre de
son successeur mais ce sera encore lui
en mars 2010neuf trouveront sûrement une
astuce pour dire on prolonge savez
pendant cinq ans tornade et la turquie
qui a demandé à entrer
peut-être non pendant 50 ans on leur a
jamais rien dit pratiquement sans 2005
elle a commencé des pourparlers
d'adhésion de la turquie alors qu'ils
ont demandé depuis 1963
eh bien les britanniques ils sont
sûrement demandé pour sortir ça peut
aussi durer 40 ans en fait cette
manifestation un samedi dernier de ses
sept cent mille personnes demandant
l'organisation rganisation d'un second
référendum est ce que c'est possible
mais dans la mentalité britannique je
crois que c'est difficilement possible
c'est une fois que ces tranchées s'est
tranché il faut 3 retrouver un artifice
peut-être pas seulement pas un
référendum à mon avis mais un artifice
et je perds je pense qu'il nous prépare
ça pendant quelques décennies ils
parlent d'un référendum sur le traité
mais pour l'instant il exhale le
résultat il parle d'un référendum sur le
traité
mais pour l'instant il n'a pas donc on
n'a pas l'imaginer mais comme le dit
marc c'est vrai c'est pas dans la
culture c'est pas dans la culture
britannique
cela a été encore une fois si toutefois
il voulait arrêter le processus
ce serait vraiment très compliqué parce
qu'il faudrait recommencer une un
processus d'entrée de alors ça pour
aller plus vite évidemment que pour la
serbie ou
quel pays mais malgré tout ça poserait
un problème de deux temps de latence
entre les deux camps et ce sera donc le
mot de la fin c'est ainsi que se termine
notre débat aujourd'hui merci à tous les
trois d'y avoir participé merci à vous
de nous avoir suivis et vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission en replay sur
nos différents sites lcpan public sénat
et rtbf.be très belle semaine à tous et
à très bientôt
[Musique]